Little Life. À hôm nay tôi sẽ ờ
quay video để mà nói về cách tôi đã làm
bài à bài phỏng vấn test thế nào. Today
I will introduce about how I
do the challenge
à interviews. À
liệu này. Thực ra là mình gửi từ 8:30
nên là em 9:30 thì em đã mở lên đọc. Và
em cũng hỏi là có thể giải thích bằng
tiếng Việt được không? Bởi vì nó sẽ khá
chu chảy hơn. Nhưng mà bên mình thì
thích tiếng Anh nên là em nghĩ là em sẽ
nói kiểu song ngữ để nói tiếng Việt
trước một cách mượt, sau đó thì dịch ra
bằng tiếng Anh.
So today
you guys sending me emails
about 8 30 o but I open email
and read read this challenge about 930.
So I first of all I I ask about
can I can I record this video explain
just in Vietnames because I will speak
more fluent and smotter that you prefer
English. So I think I will
have bow à have dual language to
translate make it clear
for me.
So hope you c understand.
Phần này nói về
đầu tiên là về cách giải quyết vấn đề
đúng không ạ? À
và 8:30 sáng đã có thông báo về cái việc
là
cái monitor đã hiển thị các thông tin
liên quan đến độ trễ về phản hồi API và
connection thì bị quá tải. Xong rồi. À
tỉ lệ er rate của cái API này tận 23% mà
thường là chỉ dưới 1%. Và và có trường
còn phản ánh lại là app bị treo đúng
không ạ? Khi mà khi mà kiểu à đây gọi là
điểm danh.
So in the morning
respond is very delay
and datab connection is po and error is
very high and some school are reporting
that is crashing or freezing
À s thì ở đây là em thấy là có cập nhật
mới cập nhật gần đây đó là thêm tính
năng về kiểu chck kingh là kiểu theo dõi
về về vụ điểm danh và
tiếp theo là thông báo tuần trước thì
thông báo thời theo thời gian thực cho
phụ huynh đấy và database đang
khá là tăng trong khoảng thời gian vừa
qua đấy. So I see that yesterday we just
deploy new attention checking. So make
it can make more cry or
some addition feature in current feature
last week that we have retime parent
notification.
So it's just another addition feature to
this
delay
and then database increase in past
month. So
we I think this is about the scale of
data. So make
the current query more slower.
giả thiết của bạn về vấn đề cốc lõi là
gì? À
và cái log là mình sẽ kiểm tra đầu tiên
cái việc là mình sẽ gọi ai đúng không ạ?
Và tại sao thì đầu tiên là mình đầu tiên
là em sẽ
như em vừa nói thì gốc dễ vấn đề ở đây
nếu mà try vấn đột nhiên lâu thì chắc
chắn là thường liên quan đến việc là
tính năng mới cập nhật đúng không ạ? Nếu
mà đây là đột nhiên lâu đúng không ạ?
mới hôm qua cập nhật tính năng mới hay
gì đó. Đấy, xong rồi à tỉ lệ câu truy
vấn lên cao các thứ các thứ thì em sẽ
điều tra dần về
đầu tiên mở cái đoạn đoạn
bởi vì cái này đã xác định
nếu mà tính năng mới này thì mình xác
định được luôn là tính có thể tính năng
mới là gây ra mình sẽ vào cái phần điểm
danh để kiểm tra luôn. Đấy, sau đó thì
mình sẽ
ờ đầu tiên là mình vào kiểm tra luôn.
Sau đó thì mình sẽ biết được mình dựa
theo lịch sử git để mình biết được là ai
là người mới đẩy đoạn này lên để mà bảo
check cùng với mình để theo dõi. Đấy,
sau đó thì mình vẫn sẽ tiếp tục điều
tra.
thì mình cách để tái hiện lại thì thường
là sẽ là thực ra là mình có thể đọc code
ra đoạn code này khá là ngắn để mình có
thể à nhìn một phát hình dung được luôn.
Nhưng mà còn nếu mà vấn đề lớn hơn thì
thường là mình sẽ chạy đoạn code này kèm
theo kiểu monitor. Ví dụ là bên mình
dùng PP thì có thể dùng các monitor
giống như là nếu mà dùng Lel chẳng hạn
đúng không ạ? thì dùng monitor của Lal T
scope hoặc là clockwork để mà mình biết
được là
à tốc độ xử lý của mỗi cái tốc độ có bao
nhiêu câu truy vấn rồi vân vân đúng
không ạ. So
the first I will I will do that
I I will
see the reason change in git. So
yesterday just deploy new
thing new feature. So I think if if this
this monitor just notice this morning
not
over the the week. So I think this
maybe this feature
will check that first and when I do when
I see
see the git that
who have responsible about this code I
will call him but I will also
pair pair program
So I think I will see the problem right
away but
if it's more complicated on production
on job production so I think I must
run that on my local and if if it
you are using PB and maybe framework
like Lal I will
use
package like
telescope or
clockwork to see the how many query and
how long is
how long is take and some and total cost
and total à response time.
vấn đề đó là N + 1 câ truy vấn. Bởi vì ở
đây ví dụ đây là truy vấn a à học sinh
đúng không ạ? Xong rồi truy vấn tiếp là
trường này, xong rồi cập nhật này, xong
rồi truy vấn à phụ huynh, sau đó thì à
lại truy vấn tiếp là đếm tổng số điểm
danh ngày hôm nay rồi cập nhật. Đấy thì
ở đây thấy vấn đề ngay đó là truy vấn
rất nhiều kết hợp việc là có truy vấn
thừa à kết hợp với việc là
thường là không nên truy vấn từng học
sinh như thế này. Xong rồi đã thế là
nghĩa là bản chất bản chất khi mà
một cái luồng tính năng hoạt động đó là
phải đi từ đi từ cha rồi đến con. Còn
đây là lại đang đi từ con rồi đến cha.
Tất cả từ cái nhỏ nhất cho đến cái lớn
nhất. Ví dụ là học sinh xong rồi đến
trường xong đến phụ huynh nghĩa là mình
đang đi ngược nên thành ra mình bị nặng.
Đấy chuẩn là mình sẽ phải đi bài toán
xuôi. Thế nên là em nghĩ là đầu tiên là
em nghĩ hot fix trước thì rõ ràng là để
liên quan việc là khách hàng đang báo là
đang bị delay nên là mình sẽ cần
phản hồi nhanh nhất cho khách hàng chứ
còn những cái liên quan đến sửa về câu
truy vấn thì sẽ có thể làm sai thì gây
lỗi gây bấc luôn là coi như là sẽ chết
luôn thì không nên là mình sẽ đầu tiên
là những cái gì mình đẩy được vào chó
thì mình sẽ xử lý luôn bởi vì nó không
sửa gì về logic mà chỉ gần như là mình
chỉ đẩy code được cái này sang khác. Thì
ví dụ là cái thông báo thì mình hiện tại
thì đang bắt người dùng có thể nhìn đoạn
này có thể đang bắt người dùng phải đợi
việc thông báo xong thì mới được thì
mình sẽ đẩy vào job đẩy vào que để nó xử
lý kiểu xử lý tuần tự từ từ. Cái này
không quan trọng. Đây không tính năng
chính là tính năng điểm danh, không phải
tính năng về thông báo hay tính năng cập
nhật gì đó này. Và thứ hai đó là cái
tính năng cập nhật này là đang phải lấy
ra dữ liệu ra xong rồi cập nhật vào. Th
không nên. Mình sẽ mình có thể với SQL
thì mình có thể dùng cái hàm là
increment là mình sẽ kiểu tự động tăng
nó luôn. Nên là mình sẽ mình sẽ kiểu tự
động tăng dần.
em có thực ra là em có dùng ai nhưng mà
em biết được luồng hoạt động rồi đầu
tiên em còn dùng ai để phân tích ra cái
bản này kết hợp việc tạo bản tiếng Việt
để cho dễ đọc đã tránh việc mình hiểu
sai vấn đề
đấy xong rồi em đã nghĩ ra tất cả các
giải pháp trước rồi đấy tuy là nói ở đây
nhưng mà em đã nghĩ ra bởi vì là mình là
công ty về product em làm công ty
Product phải em từng làm về chính hệ
thống quản lý cho nhà trường điểm danh
nên là em sẽ biết được là mình sẽ phải
sửa dần dần.
À quên em nói tiếng Anh nữa. So first of
all I think I will see the problem right
away about this
normally that a function you will go
from the root to the
to the le is about you will go from
school to to parent to child or maybe
school to try to parent to not like
try to try to parent or school because
I don't know that word but I think
reverse is not good
not good flows you will go from the root
to the bottom
so the the problem is about the query
but the main problem problem we must fix
right away is about the delay à so i
think the notification or update
update start that is not the core
function here the core function here is
about attention so
so we
to job to
not one
not need to
notif notification
right away so and more problem about
query is have two query but we don't
need that we will use increment function
in
SQL to to increase more
today attention C
so I use AI I is is to first I use AI to
summary and translate it for to English
And I also use it to make a flow answer,
but I don't I don't see it first because
I I see the code and see the detail and
I can answer that right here.
We are we are produ product company so I
think make
a lot we don't fix all right away we
make hot fix like like I just said we
have version two just you agreement to
make two query to one query
and we make this notification
notification to job so
don't have to as a client don't have to
wait while doing this
đấy thì đầu tiên là em có version 1 như
này code nó sẽ trông như này đúng không
ạ đây là em có từ bên kia ra đúng không
ạ xong rồi version 2 thì nó sẽ như này
rất đơn giản là mình có một chop này
increment xong mình sẽ đã giải quyết
được tương đối là về hiệu suất. Bởi vì
cái này đơn giản tuy là nó vẫn có nhiều
truy vấn nhưng thực ra là nó đều truy
vấn rất là ngắn và rất rất là nhanh. Bởi
vì tìm cái khóa chính xong rồi xếp thì
mọi thứ đều rất nhanh đấy nên là nó
không giải quyết được vấn đề của khách
luôn rồi. Còn về công ty Product thì
mình phải ưu luôn ưu tiên khách trước.
Còn những cái kiểu bởi vì khách sẽ luôn
nhìn thấy cái đấy đầu tiên khách không
quan tâm việc mình feedback hay mọi thứ
như thế nào đúng không ạ? Đấy.
we just move notification to job to kill
to make it
do something later we don't have to wait
that and we will transform
select and update to just increment
increment in HQL will increase that we
don't we don't have to select it to know
what what C is I we don't need this.
À
đấy. Tiếp theo là
tiếp theo là mình sẽ có bản thứ ba vì là
như mình đã nói là mình đang bị n + 1 có
truy vấn ở đây là mình đang kiểu
select tận khá nhiều lần và cứ mỗi một
học sinh là mình lại phải lấy lại thông
tin trường. Đấy là một cái nó lặp điệp
lại cho một trường rồi đúng không ạ? Bởi
vì mình khi mình điểm danh mình sẽ điểm
danh theo trường chứ mình không điểm
danh một học sinh riêng tay. Đấy và đã
thế còn lấy toàn bộ học sinh với mỗi cái
thay vì mình lấy toàn bộ parent ID xong
rồi lấy các thứ đúng không ạ? đấy là về
cái n cng n cng 1 câu truy vấn thì em sẽ
có phiên bản ở đây đó là mình sẽ lấy
theo ID này lấy theo school lấy parent
đương nhiên là school vẫn đang lặp lại
bởi vì có thể là rất nhiều học sinh cùng
một trường chữa đúng không ạ thì cái này
vẫn đang gặp lại. Ok, mình sẽ xử lý cái
này xong. Đấy, đầu tiên là mình xử lý
được n cộng một câu truy vấn đã. Và khi
mình xử lý lần lượt từng bước từng bước
như này thì mình rất dễ phải robot nếu
mà có vấn đề lỗi gì xảy ra đúng không ạ?
Tránh về việc là mình cập nhật hết của
mỗi lúc thì một là một là thì mình có
thể đẩy hết cùng một lúc cũng được. Thứ
nhất là nó lại tốn thời gian về mình
phải sửa nhiều. cái việc là
nếu có nếu vấn đề xảy ra thì mình lại
roll back lại thì nó lại quay lại chậm
đúng không ạ? mà vấn đề chưa giải quyết
nên là mình sẽ phải update từng version
đấy. So in version 3 is that we just
prevent
eagle lading prevent yeah and we we
summary that query to justice so we have
a lot of vision because I don't want to
we don't want to if something wrong we
roll back just
previous version not all the work we
have fix because
delay or one just and do nothing and one
have problem so we must have a lot of
vision to fix à slow b careful
thì em có đề xuất cả phương án bốn đó là
thay đổi cơ chế điểm danh bởi vì Vì là
như em đã nói là không có chuyện điểm
danh cho một học sinh mà mình sẽ điểm
danh cho cả một lớp cũng cùng lúc mình
sẽ đẩy lên cái mạc của danh sách sinh
viên sau đó thì mình sẽ truy vấn theo
cái danh sách đấy kèm với phụ huynh các
thứ. Thì cái này nó đôi khi liên quan cả
nên thành ra là nó sẽ ở version 4 thì sẽ
có thể làm sau. Bởi vì về cơ bản thì đến
cái version 3 này là đã kiểu đã xử lý
được về khách hàng, khách hàng trải
nghiệm có thể sẽ mượt hơn rồi. Nên là
cái này có nhiều cái truy vấn nhưng mà
nhiều đến mấy chăng nữa thì cũng bán là
DB mình có thể bị treo một tí thôi chứ
không làm quá bị delay.
Đây thì
mình sẽ có thời gian để làm version 4 và
mình test lại cẩn thận. Đấy bao gồm làm
cả fend s đây đây version 4
đây mình sẽ đẩy lên đấy mình chỉ cần
truy vấn school đúng một lần sau đó kèm
theo danh sách ID của học sinh sau đó
kèm theo phụ huynh đấy thì sau đó thì
mình sẽ đẩy cái mảng phụ huynh đấy vào
vào trong cái
vào trong cái thông báo. Thông báo này
cũng sẽ thông báo nhiều mình sẽ kiểu mặc
đấy. Rồi à increase các thứ đúng không
ạ? Incree cũng chỉ thực ra là ừ incre
theo cao nó cũng sẽ rất là nhanh.
Cái này nó sẽ khắc phục luôn cả cái việc
là mình có bao nhiêu học sinh mình phải
increase bấy nhiêu
bởi kiểu chạy bấy nhiêu câu increase nó
bị nặng câu update đúng không ạ? Đấy
nã mình sẽ incre inc incre incre
increase theo trường đúng không ạ? Theo
trường là một lần mình sẽ tăng bao nhiêu
học sinh.
Hôm nay đã điểm dành bao nhiêu học sinh.
Đấy khá nói chung là cái này làm cho tội
giảm đi rất nhiều câu truy vấn đúng
không ạ? So we have I suggest that we
have can have version four because
I said before that we must
go flow that
from root to the bottom. So we don't
à check in on every student or every
child. We must when we do the check
checkin we do all. So
something else so
and we we have ban attendant
so we just one query to
select all of that
ch ids
we will invis
version we must have time. So we just
fix à or we need to fix to make it no
more delay for the client. So we have
time to
à
see is improvement
and make change
from back front end to back end and
we send all notification one we don't
have to select that anymore and we à
when every try we make
update increment we just increase
just one
to the school so more efficiency.
that is
challenge one. I also have à đây em nói
thê việ trước ờ thì đây là cách em giải
quyết ở vấn đề thứ nhất nhưng mà thực ra
là cái này nó cũng đều có ưu và nhược
thứ nhất là nhược là gì thứ nhất là với
best practice của job thì thực ra là
mình không không có chuyện select xong
rồi mình truyền vào con job dữ liệu kiểu
một cái mảng hay một cái collection hay
một cái kiểu một cái dữ liệu lớn như này
vào trong một con job được nó cũng có
tải và nó không tốt bởi vì là database
có thể thay đổi hay vân vân gì đó thường
là mình sẽ ch truyền vào tính sách ID
sau đó mình sẽ truy vấn ở trong đấy đấy
web back tích nhất đấy
à tiếp theo là cái vụ à đếm này như thực
tế vừa rồi em đang nói thì nó là đương
nhiên từ version 3 là đang vì mình cứ up
increment nghĩa là mình update lần lượt
theo từng học học sinh thì mình đã tối
ưu hơn là cập nhật mỗi khi mà mình
truyền lên một mảng học sinh lớn đúng
không ạ để cập nhật cho trường nhưng
tính ra thì bây giờ có rất nhiều trường
thì nó vẫn tốn bấy nhiêu câu và thậm chí
là mình có điểm danh nhiều lần hay gì gì
đó thì nó lại cập nhật lại thì không
tốt. Thì cách tốt hơn ở đây đó là thường
là có thể là nếu mình muốn tối ưu hơn là
mình sẽ lưu lại vào trong cách giống như
là cách mà YouTube hồi trước cũng từng
làm. Đó là mình sẽ cứ cập nhật increment
vào trong cách sau đó thì đến cuối ngày
hoặc là bởi vì cái này là cái kiểu về
thống kê thì các bạn mình không cần cập
nhật luôn mình chỉ cần quan tâm là ngày
hôm sau hoặc là khoảng th khoảng thời
gian nào đó mình xem thì mình sẽ
mình sẽ biết được là à kiểu tổng thống
kê
đã điểm danh ngày hôm nay chưa vân vân
đúng không ạ? thì mình sẽ mình sẽ cập
nhật mình sẽ có một con k một con cron
job chạy để cứ đến một khoảng thời gian
nhất định mình sẽ cập nhật từ cách vào
trong database. Nghĩa là chỉ cần một câu
truy vấn là mình sẽ cập nhật xong. Đương
nhiên nó sẽ có ưu nhược về khoảng cứ mỗi
lần mình tối ưu thế là sẽ có lúc là mình
thay đổi dữ liệu rồi thì mình chưa cầm
nhận hay là mình tố đấy giống như vừa
nãy em nói là thay đổi dữ liệu rồi giả
sử xóa children children hoặc parent not
file mà mình truyền từ đây vào trong cái
notification nó thể gây lỗi nói chung là
nóấy bài toán đánh đổi đúng không ạ so
this last version so
it make more efficiency but it have some
risk that when you try to
all the data so and
it to the job is not very best practice
the best practice here is you
must quabase
all data. So
maybe the child or the school or the
parent have been deleted or change will
make
run a
à
it will run
and here
we can
we can make this
we can use cake so
here
I
about the static so not we don't we
don't have to update this every time we
just want to update this
daily once
one time
in in in day so we can run the job to to
to
à get formake and update to database
so just one but
it's
about balance between
effect effective efficiency to
consistency
and valid
valid data because
some data is old and sometimes the data
is changed we
à we must take that cris
the part two à phần hai về à về kiểu
quyết định của
kiểu gọi là
tách L đúng không ạ? Team L
thì ở đây em đọc đó là đang có 5000
trường
à đâu 500 trường Indo quý 3 và nó sẽ
tăng và nó
bây giờ chuẩn bị tăng gấp 10 lần hiệu
suất đúng không ạ?
Đấy mà hiện tại đang có rất nhiều rồi
vân vân đúng không ạ? Đấy thì bài toán ở
đây đó là
phân loại theo cái nào là quan trọng
nhất đúng không ạ? Và lý do tại sao đấy
thì em ở đây vẫn có dịch ra và em thấy
là đây để em dịch lại xem em hiểu đúng
không ạ. Đúng là database đang bị botton
next nghĩa là tắt nút cổ trai là gấp 10
lần câu truy vấn này. à dụng điện thoại
đang bị sập nghĩa là kiểu bị không kiểu
không dùng được tăng lên à
kiểu với thời gian với cập nhật theo
thời gian thực đấy nên nói chung là nó
bị sập khi mà liên quan đến cái tính
năng cập nhật các thứ và cái a
bộ nhớ PP thì thường hay chạm đến điểm à
kiểu đỉnh đấy. Và tiếp theo là cái chi
phí của Amazon hạ tầng thì đang kiểu
không ổn định đúng không ạ? Rồi tiếp
theo là cái việc độ trễ giữa các khu vực
đang ảnh hưởng đến trải nghiệm của khách
hàng ở Indo. Đấy thì
ty Product theo em hiểu thì đó là mình
phải luôn hướng đến khách hàng. Bởi
không khách hàng thì mình
không khách hàng thì mình cũng đi đúng
không ạ? Đấy. Thế nên là cái này là cái
quan trọng đầu tiên nó trải nghiệm cái
này lu trải nghiệm khách hàng thì mình
sẽ phải đặt mức ưu tiên cao nhất. Sau đó
thì tiếp theo là liên quan đến có thể là
một cái này là database. Bởi vì database
database thì đúng là nó ảnh hưởng đến
ngay trải nghiệm khách hàng.
Bởi vì database mà treo thì thì đúng là
chẳng có gì hoạt động cả. Đấy. Và cái
này là liên quan đến a
à appỉnh thoảng à bị sập đúng không ạ?
Thì thường là một là mình phải kiểm tra
lại là như em cái bài thứ nhất là mình
sẽ kiểu ưu tiên cái nào trước c những
cái tính năng chính thì vẫn sẽ như nào
đấy nhưng cái này là cần phải giả soát
lại thì cái đầu tiên mình cần làm là
mình có thể rate limit lại nó đã để
tránh việc là nó retime nhiều có nhiều
cái là mình không cần phải xử lý retime
mình xử lý kiểu gọi là cho delay một tí
cũng được và nếu mà bị nhiều quá thì đôi
khi là bị spam thì mình sẽ nói chung là
rate limit nó sẽ giải quyết được cái
việc này.
Đấy thì em nghĩ là hai cái này sẽ ưu
tiên. Có thể là nếu mà em thì em sẽ ưu
tiên mức hai rồi ba cái này hoặc là hai
cái này hoặc ba này cũng được. Thì em
thấy là nó đều ảnh hưởng đến liên quan
đến trải nghiệm nguy dụng. Mình vẫn bài
kim chỉ nam mình vẫn là trải nghiệm
người dùng bởi người dùng quan trọng
nhất. Tiếp theo là
cái này thì đúng là ảnh hưởng đến có thể
nó sẽ làm đấy quá tải cái gì gì đó. Thực
ra là mình cách làm mình cái đầu tiên
mình có thể làm nó chỉ đơn giản là là
mình tăng bộ nhớ lên mình có thể tốn
tiền hơn nhưng mà mình sẽ tăng bộ nhớ
lên để giải quyết được đã. Bởi vì rõ
ràng mình tăng khách hàng thì cũng tăng
được cái nguồn thu rồi nên là mình có
thể làm được cái giải quyết này giải
quyết nhanh được. Rồi mình có thời gian
thì mình sẽ đi vào để kiểm tra xem vấn
đề nằm ở đâu. Thường là liên quan đến xử
lý nghìn đến triệu cái cùng lúc đấy.
Triệu cầu truy vấn cùng lúc hồi trước ví
dụ em làm cái vụ import data chịu bản
khi của SQL à của Excel thì thường là nó
sẽ đúng là tăng cái memory limit lên thì
mình sẽ giải phóng dung lượng bằng cách
nhiều cách đúng không ạ? Và cuối cùng là
chi phí hạ tầng các thứ thứ này thì rõ
ràng cái này thì thì như em nói nó giống
cái trên này nó là cái này mình sẽ xử lý
sau mình không phải là mức độ ưu tiên vì
rõ ràng là mình đang tăng khách và có
khách đang dùng là mình là mình đang có
nguồn thua rồi có thể mình đang lãi rồi
đấy đúng không ạ thì mình
có thể cân nhắc cái này sau vì nếu mà
mình cứ tập trung vào việc tiết kiệm các
thứ các thứ thì khách đi thậm chí là có
lượng khách đến này nó sẽ không thể dùng
được thì sẽ mất khách. So I just
translate all in Vietnames
by how I understand the problem. So the
à So I run that the first highest is
about growth region latency effect. So
we are product company so we must focus
about the the customer the experience.
So I don't So we don't want to lose a
customer because
à
in Vietnamese we have
something that customer eat got
so we must focus on them. So we don't
have one we
don't want to effect all customer. We
have
so we don't have to affect exams.
Maybe we will have a server on
local region in ID to
make them have better
transition
and smoother
tourist is equal because one data
database
it will affect everything when database
scratch or just delay so I think the
database very important but also the app
cash is
not very good experience for customer
because
I think
the customer use mobile app so
and database cannot fix right away so
we will
update great limit for mobile ad because
some some update is not very when à we
need to retime update. We just
customer can
wait
one or two second
is not very bad.
They just don't want to crash every time
they use it. So
I think
maybe database is number two and mobile
app is number three. But the mobile app
fix is very easy
and we will do research later.
we
we are facing that we will have a lot
new customer so we must increase the
memory by
spending money
or increase the
and the à
the server isord
it's very very easy to fix first hot fit
first so we will have time to research
and
attention ler and also the Amazon
service cost
we will have a lot of customer so we
and we are
app that have lot of customer so we make
them feel that we are
very strong and very reliable
application so we don't we don't make
have a lot customer I think we will have
a lot of
financial so
the cost we can handle that we don't
we are not the startup because the
startup
they
have a lot money so they will make it
more higher about higher risk about cost
but we are
we are large company so we don't need to
think that
priority
đầu tiên có ba phương án là mình cần
phải làm đúng không ạ? Làm một là sửa
các vấn đề liên quan đến hiệu năng. Hiệu
suất nghĩa là tốc độ xử lý chậm. Đấy em
đang hiểu nhá đúng không ạ? À phải cần
cả một đội à toàn bộ đội, toàn bộ đội ở
đây em đang không thấy con số em cứ đặt
giả sử bài toán là sáu người đi đúng
không ạ? Tiếp theo là làm tính năng cho
bên Indo mà chỉ phù hợp với bên Indo
thôi và mất bốn người tận ba tuần. Xong
rồi. Đây là thêm cái vụ theo dõi monitor
và thậm chí cảnh báo thông báo khi có
vấn đề về hệ thống mất một tuần hai
người thì CEO thì muốn làm tất cả trong
vòng hai tuần. Thì rõ ràng đây nghe bài
toán lúc đầu là không thể đúng không ạ?
Thì cái nào mình ưu tiên hơn tại sao
mình giải thích với CEO thế nào và nói
với à thành viên các thành viên như thế
nào?
Thì à bài toán ở đây em thấy đầu tiên
thì chắc chắn là không thể làm hết được
cùng lúc thì và vì nói chuyện với CEO
nữa cái việc là em cũng từng làm tuy em
không làm techlist nhưng mà em làm công
ty Product thì em biết được cái vấn đề ở
đây đó là mình phải luôn thể hiện được
là mình có làm chứ không phải sau hai
tuần là mình chỉ làm một tính năng hay
gì đó đưa ra ba đầu việc nhưng mình làm
mới chỉ xong một đầu việc là không nên
là chắc chắn là em sẽ không đâm đơ vào
cái toàn bộ dồn người vào phương án B
hay là toàn bộ người vào phương án A.
Đấy thì em sẽ thường là em sẽ làm em
nghĩ là làm song song sẽ là bốn giả sử
là team có sáu người đúng không ạ? Bốn
người ở B và Hạ và hai người ở C. Vì
theo em một cái dự án đang vốn đang chạy
thì hoặc là thậm chí là đang sắp cho một
lượng tệp khách hàng rất là lớn thì cái
đầu tiên mình cần làm là làm một cái a
một cái bản để mà theo dõi đúng không ạ?
để nếu có vấn đề bấc gì xảy ra trên thì
mình sẽ xem được luôn để tránh việc là
vì ở đây cái này liên quan hệ suất là có
thể là bị chậm hay gì đó khách hàng có
thể đợi được còn hơn là nó không chạy
đúng không ạ thì rõ ràng là có b thì đôi
khi khách hàng sẽ phản hồi mình nhưng
đôi khi khách sẽ đi luôn khách không
phản hồi gì cả vì thấy là phần mềm đểu
không dùng được không tán tin cận họ sẽ
đi nên thành ra là mình sẽ phải ưu tiên
cái c Thì lúc đấy là em thì sau một tuần
đúng không ạ? Sau một tuần là hai người
đã làm xong thì hai người này sẽ quay ra
sửa những cái vấn đề liên quan đến về
hiệu năng. Thì rõ ràng là hiệu vấn đề
hiệu năng có rất nhiều thì đương nhiên
là hai người không đủ nhưng mà và vấn đề
hiệu năng sẽ luôn có ở trên sản phẩm
production trừ khi mình không phát triển
đến tính năng mới và thỉnh thoảng
database mà scale thì thực ra nó vẫn
sinh vấn đề thì cái vấn đề hiệu năng
luôn luôn có đấy nên là hai người sàng
hai người thì đương nhiên là cũng sẽ fix
được một cách tương đối gì đó trong vòng
một tuần đấy còn à về tính năng này thì
bốn người đang làm thì sau hai tuần
đương nhiên vẫn chưa xong nhưng hai tuần
em khẳng định là sẽ xong được bản demo
để mà nói được với khách hàng là tôi đã
có như thế này đấy tránh việc là mình
dồn sang option a hay option c xong rồi
hai tuần sau hai tuần khách hàng hỏi thì
mình lại bảo mình chưa làm gì cả thì
khách sẽ đi. Đấy, đấy là cách mà em sẽ
làm và anh sẽ nói chuyện với CEO. So,
nó tính bài toán về rồi ro các thứ đúng
không ạ? So I will priority and tell the
reason and how to communicate this two
CEO. So we have to
we obvious see that we can done we
cannot done
thing in two weeks because we are the
team is
option to must fix all this in two weeks
and
must have all in high team. So
in in case that we don't h anym person
because
more person
and make make make them that
and understand all the thing we
do something we
make
see that we have process but we cannot
done all the thing so
I don't priority the option one option
I are priority option three are C and
B and C first so
it just take two à and I
in this case I think in team maybe six
person So
we we will use that resource in option B
and C. So just one week two person will
make all done monitor and alerting. So
monitor and alerting is very important
to product company because the when the
customer have problem
they
may contact us or maybe not. They just
don't
leave us anymore because the app grass
and delay or something else. So they
just left they just leave they don't
want earth anymore. So we don't want
that. So I think the monitor and system
is very important to the the product
company
and when that two person dog in the two
week they will go to the option a to fix
performance the product company have a
lot of
performance issue because it are the
more scale and
the problem about the performance
we have a lot when we have a new feature
like the example
above so
two person will
fix
in one week maybe some some problem
I think
so the new feature we four person cannot
done that in
two weeks. But but
I think two week is enough for the demo.
So we can show it for the customer and
the CEO. So CC that we have process so I
think it's very clear that we have done
all three option but in
resort Q h and have still have
efficiency.
cũng sẽ trình bày tương đương như thế
với mỗi đội để biết được chứ em nghĩ là
không tránh việc hay là
à mình không thể nhét toàn bộ cả team
vào làm dự án kiểu này để hy vọng nó
song sớm được. Bởi vì như em nói thì
tính năng C cũng quan trọng, tính năng A
thì ra là nó quan trọng phần nào. Nhưng
mà ám chỉ là nếu mình dồn hết làm vào
cái này cũng chưa chắc được. Vì mình làm
lập trình viên mình sẽ hiểu là không
phải cứ đông người là sẽ giải quyết được
nhanh đúng không ạ? Đôi khi tạo thêm vấn
đề đấy. So I will tell the member like I
just said because very clear. So
à
when the option C is very important so
we cannot miss up and the we can we
cannot
use all the resour
team in the option B to make it more
faster because
like as a developer I understand that
more people is not
shorter the
the time because maybe cause more
problem we must communicate and
understand each other so
conflict something else so I think
that is my
myw
nhiều và nó bị dài hơn so với quyết định
nhưng mà em nghĩa là nó sẽ khá là rõ
ràng bởi vì là em đã trình bày trên cả
tất cả kiểu khá là rõ rõ đúng không ạ?
Về và cũng khá là kiểu bài bản. Ờ
tuy nhiên nó sẽ đi kèm với em vừa nói cả
ưu và nhược các thứ rồi đúng không ạ?
Và tiếp theo là em nói gì về cái trải
nghiệm cái thử thách này? Thứ đây là
những lần hiếm ho em đã phỏng vấn và đây
là lần đầu tiên em làm cái bài thử thách
thì em thấy rất ấn tượng và rất là hay
cũng như là
nó cho em cảm thấy thêm về năng lực của
bản thân mình là biết được là ừ mình làm
được.
Và à em tiếp theo là
it's not very short because I do it in
language and I
have show you my thought a lot so
it's not just
just all rec
more complicate than that. So I this is
the first time I do this kind of
challenge
interview. So I think it
very very good and I and it help me that
I know
what position I am what level I am. So I
very happy after this challenge.
mọi người có thấy là em đã sử dụng AI
trong việc là vừa tóm tắt vừa phân tích
cũng như là thậm chí cả code luôn. Thì
thực tế em làm bây giờ cũng thế nghĩa là
em sẽ phân tích trước. Em thứ các em
nghĩ một lập trình viên là sẽ thế. lập
trình viên nó không phải là người viết
lại những dòng code không phải ngồi gõ
lại. Đấy giống kiểu thư ký hơn hoặc
coder hơn. Developer nó sẽ là nhà phát
triển tức là người dựa trên những cái gì
đã có xong rồi mình sẽ ngồi phân tích để
mà
mình sẽ đưa kế hoạch để làm. Thì gần như
là bây giờ là lập trình viên giống như
một PM hơn và AI sẽ là công cụ để mà
mình làm. Đương nhiên, đương nhiên là có
những cái mình vẫn phải tự code bởi vì
vì mình phải có những cái button chuẩn
để cho ai học theo để mà ai biết được là
mình dựa theo cái design button nào đấy.
Tránh việc là nó tự nghĩa là code rồi
code cứ loạn hết cả lên và không clean
đúng không ạ?
So I
I show you guys
guys may think that I lot about the
summary and
deeper is not coder. We don't write we
don't
write down the code repe repeatly. We
must think first and make plan that we
must deploy
that application already have but in
some case we must
design first and
must write clean code have
button first so AI can
learn for to à make code à make new code
à
l pattern and make it clear and clean.
gửi lại code đúng không ạ?
comment này video này.
hope I can see you guys soon.
Yeah.